COLT MCANLIS: In this episode
of Cloud Performance Atlas,
we take a look at
Bigtable's monitoring UI
to find out our
performance edge cases.
Will we scale to
meet the challenge?
Stay tuned to find out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
When you're dealing
with something
at the scale of
Bigtable, performance
is always on your mind.
Bigtable's ability to
handle billion user systems
happens almost entirely behind
the scenes, where front-ends
can coordinate balance
and optimize your access
patterns without you
having to lift a finger.
But even the best systems need
a little attention now and then.
Thankfully, the monitoring
UI is here to help.
The Bigtable UI in
the Cloud console
has a built-in monitoring tool
that automatically reports
how your nodes, clusters, and
instances are performing--
showing things like
CPU utilization, error
rate, and storage utilization
all in a handy graph form,
so that at a glance, you can
see how your systems have
been performing.
And while having this
graph data is great,
what's really important
is finding the situations
where it actually
tells you something.
Here's a few common
use cases that
are worth keeping an eye on.
As mentioned before,
Bigtable works
by keeping a set of
front-end nodes, which
are responsible for routing
and bouncing traffic
to the back-end tables.
When you create your
Bigtable instance,
you specify the number
of nodes you want.
And using the
Monitoring tool, you
can quickly see if it's
time to add more nodes.
On our Instances tab,
we can take a look
at the CPU utilization
table, which
has a recommended max line.
This line represents the best
practices for CPU utilization.
And if you eclipse this line
for a number of minutes,
it's generally a good idea to
add more nodes to your cluster.
Now, another common performance
problem with Bigtable
is asymmetric reads and
writes on a cluster.
For example, suppose
that 25% of your reads
are going to a small number
of tablets within a cluster,
while the rest are spread
evenly across the other tablets.
When Bigtable detects
this happening,
it will redistribute
the existing tablets,
so that reads are spread
as evenly as possible
across the entire cluster.
Now, we can detect this
pattern in the monitoring tool
by keeping an eye on the CPU
utilization of the hottest
node graph.
That's a lot of air quotes.
If the hottest
node is frequently
above the recommended
value, even when
your average CPU
utilization is reasonable,
then you'll need to go
back and check your schema
design to update your
access patterns accordingly.
Now, if you want to drill
deeper into your schema design
challenges, then you might
want to take a look at the Key
Visualizer tool, which provides
a really fancy heat map
visualizer that can
help you figure out
where your schema design
might be going off the rails.
But that's a topic
for another episode.
If you're interested
to know more,
then check out the article
linked in the description
below.
And don't forget to subscribe
to our YouTube Cloud
channel for other great
Performance Atlas content--
because when it
comes to performance,
every millisecond counts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]